இந்த உலகத்திலியோ அடுத்த உலகத்திலியோ அடுத்த பிறவிலியோ உடனே கடிக்கலாம்
சாப்டா உடனே பசி தீரும் பலன்
பராக்டிஸ் பண்ணா போட்டியில் கலந்துகொள்ளலாம்
தொங்கப்ப கடுமையாக பராக்டிஸ் பண்ணா போட்டியில் ஜெய்கிக்கலாம்
டீட்டுக்குப் பிரபேர்பட்டுவிட்டால் டீட்டு தொடர்புகிறால் மருத்துவராக இருக்கலாம்
இது வந்து கொஞ்சம் கர்மாவின் சிறிய விஷயத்தைப் பலன் தெரியும் நமக்கு
நிறைய வழக்குகள் தெரியும் மறுபடியும் என்பது மட்டும் நமக்குப் புரியமாட்டேன்
அதே மாதிரி சொன்னால் இன்னொரு விஷயம் தவ்வான செயலில் போறவன் அதில் ஒரு கேள்வி தோன்றிக்கொண்டு இருக்கிறது
நீங்கள் கேட்டிருக்கும் கேள்விகளில் கேர்ச்செல்ல முடியுமா?
அதில்தான் கிளோதிஸ்ஸம் இது எல்லாம் இருக்கிறது
கர்மா தீரியில் நம்பிக்கின்றால் முடியாது நம்முடைய செய்தத்திற்கு கிடைக்கத்தான் கிடைக்கலாம்
ஆனால் நமக்கு அதைத் தாங்கக்கூடிய எமோசியல் கிடைக்கலாம் தானம் செய்வது நாளியோ தீர்த்தியாத்தில் போவது நாளியோ
பிறகு நிறைய நன்றாக இருக்கிறது கேள்விகள் எல்லாமே தீரியில் தலையில் துப்பாக்கி வைத்து நம்மைத் தப்பாரம் செய்யச் சொன்னான்
அதுக்கு என்ன ஆகும் அதும் அதேதான்
இழிச்சி அதற்கும் பலன்னமாகக் கிடைக்கும்
மனுநீதி சோழன் மாதிரி தன் பையனை
ரதத்தைக் கொள்ள வைச்சு நசுக்குற அடிடுடு இருந்தால்
நான் செத்தாலும் பரவாயில்லை நான் நீ சொல்வதை செய்யமாட்டேன்
சுட்டு தள்ளு வேண்டாம் அவளின் சொல்வதை ஏறியம் இருந்தால் அது வேண்டாம்
நமக்கும் சில வீக்னஸ்ஸ் இருக்கு, அப்போது நாம் செய்யும், நான் செய்யலாய் என்னவென்று சுப்பாக்கி காட்டி மிரட்டி செய்யவைச்சான், சொல்லிக்கலாம்
ஆனால் சட்டம் வந்து நம்மை பணிக்காது. அது வந்து கொடுக்கவேண்டிய தண்டனையும் கொடுக்கும்
சின்னப்பையன் 14 வயது கீழே கர்ப்பழித்து ரேப் செய்துவிட்டான், அவனுக்கு தட்டனை மாறலாம் என்று தெரிவுகிறேன். அவனுக்கு எச்சரிப்ஷன் இல்லை.
மாதிரி சத்தம் ஒன்று, தர்மமும் ஒன்று, பல சமயும் இரண்டு ஒன்றாகத்தான் இருக்கிறது.
சில சமயும் தர்மமும் ஒன்று ஒரு விஷயம் சொல்வது, சத்தம் வேறு விஷயம் சொல்வது, எதுவும் ஆறாக இருக்கிறது.
சரி, அதெல்லாம் நாம் நிறைய ஆராய்ச்சிகளில் செய்ய முடியும். சமுதாயத்தை பெரிய அளவில் உழுகித்து வைத்திருக்கிறது என்பது உண்மை.
சிறிது வயது என்னுடைய வீட்டில் வந்து பொய் சொன்னால் மோயலரம் கிடைக்காதே என்று தெரியும் என்றால் சொல்லுவேன். நான் ஒரு எட்டு பத்துகள் இருக்கிறேன்.